[Music]
thank you hey we uh have a bit of a
tragedy here of course we do we're
waiting for one I don't care what
tragedy it is I'm bringing it back
to yes you know what's funnyest too is
like usually when we're we have all
these news articles most of them are sad
today's been pretty light I news is
right I'll make it lighter
say a veteran fried chicken
cook no finish the statement died after
fainting and falling face first into his
walk of hot
oil cuz it's sad so yeah no I was on
board it's like a blunder you know and
that's that's the news so there a part
where you got RI that's it cut it he
just passed out into the oil or he
tripped and fell he fainted he fainted
people be fainting a lot 58-year-old
like seen fried chicken cook from
Malaysia it's apparently quite famous
for his Fried Chicken oh and he just
[__] fainted became his passion he
prob that's what I was thinking about I
didn't want to say it he tried himself I
saw you need to take your electrolytes
man do you think he fainted because it's
hot in Malaysia and he had a heat stroke
and he's probably working all [__] B
you just said you need to take your
electrolytes the second I walked in here
you started telling me that you were
eating enough fats just so your
fingernails don't fall off that's cuz my
coach told me maybe his coach was
telling him oh body don't don't do a
bodybuilding next to Hot Oil that's not
okay that's where he went wrong dude
when you were cutting that like amount
of calories did you feel like you could
just faint at any time I blacked out
every time I stood up wo so every time I
stood up that sounds kind of sick
actually every time I stood up I have to
go like this and you saw a star and then
I can move or else I'll just black you
don't even eat any casamigos you're just
like just don't
eat so like I was like backing up like
at least I don't know 100 times a day
like I would have to like get up and
then like go oh [__] that sounds
terrible and then and then go up hey
when you all like we're like not even
eating that much and all of a sudden you
ate sugary ass cereal did you go yeah it
felt crazy like it felt like Goosebumps
[__] electricity like going up and
down my neck it felt crazy cuz my first
thing of carbs was on the meal plan was
a half a box of cereal so went from like
zero carbs to a half a box of cereal
like cuz a couple days before the show
you want to carb up so you feel full and
I was like okay here we go and as I was
eating I was like oh God how good did it
taste [__] so good man it's the best
I like he's thinking about it right now
it does sound kind of good right now I'm
living through him cinnamon to crush yes
dude imagine the first kid that they
gave that to they're like they're like
here I can eat this but like like
they're testing it out before they get
rid of they like get like a bunch of
kids and and they give them like they
tape their iPhones up in the thing and
they there's a call back I'm sorry I
can't got to stop the callbacks he gives
them the Cinnamon Toast Crunch and then
the kid eats it and he just
[__] He's King out think about the
first time you had Cinnamon Toast Crunch
it changed your life what if that kid
though just like he was hella spoiled in
high class and stuff and he's been
tasting [__] all these different SE
Like Rice Krispies treats and [__]
all the Corn Pops and stuff and he's
like this is all right I feel like I
feel like cinnamon toast crunch was
pretty early on in child abuse is okay
if they're like shut the [__] up give
this [__] Cinnamon Toast Crunch I
feel like I feel like cinnamon toast
crunch was pretty early on in the Cal
game am I wrong yeah so we lived in a
good ERA where our parents didn't have a
healthy alternative they're like [__] it
they're like ooh this has vitamin A and
just hook you up with Lucky Charms we
also beli the wrong food pyramid that
was huge wait wait what you know what
the food pyramid you know the FDA Food
Pyramid I remember saying things like
[__] cereal is all good like that
yeah we grew up where like protein was
at the top and carbs and fat was the
most you should consume at the bottom of
the dude those guys are
idiots it's the opposite yeah it's
opposite the opposite we've been
swindled like this but that was a good
good ERA anybody got favorite cereal you
know I used to I used to but less people
were fat back then no oh man but until
more well now it's just like but I think
we see now is a result of that pyramid I
think that marketing and we just got
more people now you know oh I remember
when um we used to get Lucky Charms a
lot and my mom would get pissed because
I would eat all the marshmallows now
they make them with just the
marshmallows really I think it's so
overrated not too much Cal milk Lucky
Charms that's pretty good yeah just the
marshmallows no cuz I get the cereal and
I just eat all the marshmallows and then
I put it back up and so they they bu
like where the [__] is the marshmallows
what's everyone's favorite cereal in
here go quick to Crunch baby Frosted
Flakes kind of gu [__] golden grams
golden GRS n better than golden grams I
I had I had eras it's a rotation okay he
was like he's a connoisseur Barry Kicks
Berry kicks no yes that was I enjoyed
them but it was never close to a
favorite I had I definitely had Cinnamon
Toast Crunch I definitely had Corn Pops
I definitely had uh Rice Krispies Treats
I definitely had Apple Jacks and then my
my oldest era was honey O's I did like
the Honey Bunches of boats honey honey o
is different the yellow small box and
it's just [__] super sweet chocolate
rice crispy
treats cuz it makes their milk chocolate
mine was cookie crisps yeah cookie yeah
cie Crisp that's not a [__] I us like
Apple Jack so much that I would steal my
sister's Froot Loops and take all the
orange and green ones
only you're a pain in the ass you're
kind of a psycho it's called a little
brother back up yeah dude I wish I had a
sister I
could do you guys remember the cinnamon
roll one yes yeah it was Cinnabon
Cinnabon yeah yeah yeah they came out
with the yeah that was pretty good that
was hella good yeah we were [__]
spoiled yeah dude we were pieces of [__]
did you ever make ghetto cereal what's
that sometimes you don't have it so you
get saltin crackers and you crunch it up
throw it milk and then pour sugar on it
you act like that's something that we
all did like that's just you bro bro
that's pretty [__] ganger dude that's
GH as [__] that's pretty [__] it's
Chinese cereal my mom called
it that's that's what my mom would do
she would take whole milk cuz I wouldn't
drink the whole milk and she puts uh
sugar in it be like this is soy milk now
that's not soy milk cuz it would taste
like soy milk really yeah it would okay
Mr [__] crackers yeah salty crackers
with sugar is W I've never heard I
actually I was I told Tao I was like hey
want to eat something that Papa used to
love and he's like yeah so I got it I
got the saltine crackers like I throw it
in there and I put sugar I mix it up and
I'm like this what Pap used to eat every
day he was
like why anybody eat this he's like we
were [__] poor he's like we're rich
now daddy we have to eat this [__]
throws it off man oh I actually kind of
want to try that it's pretty good what
what what is like what do you feed your
kid I'm actually curious like what does
he eat wag you kid stuff is it different
than when you so I give him kids stuff
cuz I don't want to like take away his
childhood but I moderate it though so
like he's giving him boiled chicken he's
like get big now he's on a cut so in the
morning I'll give him like a egg and
maybe like a sausage or whatever and
then I'm like after you eat these two
you can do whatever you want so then you
can have like a bowl of cereal or if he
wants like a peanut butter jelly
sandwich but I just have them have the
protein first and afterwards do you're a
[__] good dad dude leg that's a good
dad thing to do my dad used to just beat
the [__] out of me why don't you listen
to me yeah that's why I would listen to
him and I would still get the [__] beat
out cuz I want him to have fun too I
don't want him to be like go to school
and then he shares like the weirdest my
dad makes me eat chicken breast all day
or whatever you know [__] up you know
what you know what I love as a kid that
I thought was a sick ass balanced
breakfast with fruits in them what
Pop-Tarts dude we all thought thatp
Tarts yeah I didn't like Pop-Tarts
growing up real strawberries [__] they
were kind of sweet huh they berries
Cherry one is the best Cherry eat cherry
cherry one strawberry dude it's cuz I
didn't know that you have to do it uh
toasted very run-of-the mail but once it
was toasted I was like oh my god dude
did you ever have those Toaster strudles
I love the [__] over here dude [__]
toaster strudel the egg ones were so
good and you [__] put the thing on
and you're like wait there's not enough
not never enough there's not enough they
were flaky
too dud we all are getting cancer very
early for sure sure dude half the food
we ate was all SAR pound cake oh yeah
pound in the freezer too
yeah dude have you seen a kid cuisine
now dude it looks disgusting W remember
kid cuine it's now bro no no no it's
still the same but like go go on Tik Tok
it's like a TV dinner was a kid cuisine
but it was like in those little blue
trays and it had like a brown it was
like you all heat it up together it was
like brownie mac and cheese it dude it
was insane salry steak Yeah look at it
now you're like I can't believe they fed
this to people but low key though when I
remember the first time I got mine cuz
you'd watch on the commercials and you
get it you're like this is not good at
all yeah just feel so I loved
it everything as a kid was bomb like
that yeah I love microwave dinners dude
remember Hamburger Helper Hamburger
Helper banging breast milk was fire back
then dude back when it was
purek back back when was pure and never
all this tainted [__] in
it I remember when I first had hungry
man I felt like hungry man bro and then
I was in shock because of the big pieces
of chicken or like the meatloaf and I'm
like wow yeah cuz you're a hungry
man hungry man for some reason now I'm
thinking about Oreo McFlurries oh dude
they don't have n you guys are going to
[__] the rest of my day dude they still
have them [__] yeah hey lowkey
McDonald's got one with a with a peanut
butter
mcfur dude I will say what [__] gets
me angry have you seen the fast food in
Europe and the fast food here is it way
better over there dude when you go get
chicken McNuggets I got chicken
McNuggets in Scotland bro they're like
legitimate like as if you go to Whole
Foods and get chicken breast like that's
the type of food because they have such
does it taste better though so much
better bro they have they have like
curry sauce and stuff they got way
better sauces everywhere else fake
chicken me too dude but no there's just
such a higher like um like they have a
higher standards for the food that they
feed I think it's something about their
people caring about each other yeah what
the [__] is up with this American bro
have you like when you go to McDonald's
and you see what they give you like you
look at the commercial you're like that
looks unbelievable and you get it and it
looks just sad dude it looks like that
burger from SpongeBob like the old
Burger you know what I'm talking about
the mil one yeah yeah dude cuz the I've
been seeing people go to like Europe or
other places like out of the states
going to McDonald's and they'll talk
about the comparison and it does look
unreal it does it's we're getting the
short of the St KFC in Jamaica is crazy
like dude it's all different everywhere
else we're why do you think the Fried
Chicken in Jamaica is crazy but I dude I
didn't bring I just said specifically
the KFC if you've been to Jamaica you
know it's better I was just wondering
you're the one that just brought that up
that's you're definitely the one who's
talking about it [__] dude I'm I'm I'm
like imagining they probably got like
jerk chicken or something different that
we don't have no for sure yeah you're
making it too real man it's true it
would be so good though hey I'll tell
you this during the bird flu when
everyone was scared of it I at KFC in
China yep straight to the source my boy
to the [__] dude you can survive
[Laughter]
anything